i got half a million dollars in shark
tank and this is that story
this was definitely the most intense day
of my life but to explain how i got here
i need to back up a bit i was not the
type of kid who was into computers
they were for boys i thought that video
games were for my brother and not for me
i had applied to a bunch of colleges one
of the ones i got into was an
engineering school and when i visited
i met the most amazing women there were
probably only 20
of the class that were actually female
but every single one of them
was the smartest coolest girl i'd ever
met and i wanted them all to be my best
friends
after college i decided to get a job as
a programmer
i kept looking around and seeing all
these rooms full of men
there were 50 people in the office and
two of us were women i wondered where
all the women were
how did half of the population of the
world get socialized against
learning about technology and learning
about computer science like why didn't
anyone tell me
when i was a little kid how awesome
programming was going to be i really
hoped that i could find a way to fix
this problem i saw that
programming was the most important skill
of the 21st century
but i also saw how the syntax and the
technical difficulties were turning
people away
i realized that maybe it could be
something that was more visual
more touch-based so that any kid could
learn
the joys and creativity of programming
so in 2013
we launched hopscotch we started to
build this community of kids coding and
learning from
each other and the games they made were
so creative and interesting
and we immediately started growing all
the press wanted to write about us
more and more users signed up and it was
an amazing feeling
i was being put on 30 under 30 lists my
co-founder was listed as one of fast
company's most creative people
someone wrote a wikipedia page about me
we were just flying on top of the world
but then the media died down as great as
all attention was
the app was free and we didn't have any
revenue so we started selling
subscriptions
and spent four years building hopscotch
into a profitable business
but just barely we're kind of breaking
even worried that we're just going to
slowly die out of business
or you know kind of stay steady for the
rest of time and never actually achieve
our goals
we only had a team of five we're really
small
to get to the next level we would have
to raise more money but we didn't have
the numbers to do that
and that's when i got a linkedin message
from a shark tank producer
asking me if i would be interested in
being on the show i realized that was my
ticket out to
start growing the company get more
investment and start building
the product that we knew hopscotch could
be had a call with the casting producer
his job was just to look for cool
companies that he thought might be
good on shark tank and he thought that
ours might be a good fit but i wasn't
automatically on shark tank after that i
still had to submit an audition video
so i made the video with my computer on
my bookshelf
in my tiny little bedroom in brooklyn
just doing
take after take after take of me trying
to pitch
hopscotch i submitted the video to my
surprise
i was chosen to get to the next round
which was
not to actually be on shark tank but to
start putting together a pitch in case
they chosen me to be on
shark tank that actually lasted
basically the whole summer the producers
helped me out
with making sure my pitch would be good
for tv but i never knew whether i would
actually be on the show
and then finally got the call that i was
chosen to film an episode of shark tank
so i called up all my friends to do a
video call with me
and hear my pitch and then ask me
questions as if they were the sharks
it was so painful i just stuttered over
myself
i was awful for the probably the first
like five days of doing this
so i had no idea how real shark tank
would actually be
and how they would edit it or whether
being on the show would feel the same as
watching myself
on it later the day that we filmed i was
in a waiting room with three other
companies who
were also pitching on shark tanks the
same day we all
got together and started doing our
pitches for each other which was pretty
funny it was really fun to see everyone
else's pitches
and then finally it was my turn to film
i was so nervous
before the show started i didn't know
what would happen
you haven't not fallen on your face yet
and i felt like i was gonna like fly out
of my skin
so i pitched the sharks in the tank and
then i gave them ipads to try hopscotch
they were making drawings they were
showing me what they made
it was really cool so damon you know i
thought we could connect on our last
names and we did
but then he was out he didn't like the
space so next was lori
i thought we were going to connect
because she is very supportive of women
she liked my energy but she was out she
said she didn't think she could help out
our business
then kevin i had very high hopes for
because i knew that he had been in the
ed tech space and he had started reader
rabbit and oregon trail
but it turned out he had vowed to
himself he would never go back
so he was out then there was barbara she
said you look scared are you scared and
i was so
pissed that she said that i was trying
very hard not to look young and not look
like a scared girl but i turned it
around
and i said of course i'm scared anyone
would be scared to make a big pivot on
their business
and to mess with something that's
working to go for something bigger
but i still know it's the right thing to
do and i think i earned her respect
there
but she was out and then finally there
was only mark left
mark had been the shark that i wanted
the most
he cares about coding he's been in
videos for code.org
he has a non-profit about coding and
during the pitch
he told me i look up to you my kids have
used hopscotch
thank you for everything you've done
which was such an amazing moment
but also you know he kind of said it in
a way like
you're amazing you know in the way that
someone like before they break up with
you or before they tell you bad news
tells you all the nice things but he did
give me an offer
he said i'm needing an offer and you're
not going to like it
which i did not like it he gave me a
quarter of the valuation that i had
asked for
i asked for 400 000 for 4 equity
he offered 16 equity and that was the
one part
i didn't prepare for i didn't actually
practice the negotiation
because i think in my mind i didn't
really expect to get a deal
or maybe i thought that if i did get a
deal they would just give me exactly
what i asked for
i actually majored in math in college
and it turns out
i forgot it all because i could not
calculate for the life of me during that
negotiation
i countered with six hundred thousand
for four percent
which was a higher valuation than i had
originally asked for
i just completely flubbed the numbers
he looked at me and he was like no i
can't do that
so i was about to walk away and then i
realized i had gotten the math wrong
and i stopped myself and i said oh my
gosh i got the math wrong which of
course made it on tv
i asked if i could do 600 000 for 10
of the company and then mark countered
with 500 000 for 11
and then i countered finally with 550
000 for 11
mark looked at me and he said you have a
deal and it was great
since shark tank aired mark is now an
investor and i send him updates
once a week he's one of the most
involved investors i've ever had
he always replies to my emails he's
always sending me new ideas for
hopscotch
he's so great and i'm so grateful to
have him on my team
we got 500 increase in users afterwards
it's been a really wild ride and i
wouldn't trade it for the world
[Music]
you